more students across the country
returning to school this week and that's
highlighting a growing crisis with
teachers there are simply not enough of
them right now government figures show
that about 300 000 teachers
left the education workforce left the
profession since february 2020 that
would be when the coveted pandemic began
and in states like mississippi florida
and nevada they've been hit especially
hard by these shortages columbus ohio
meanwhile the state's biggest school
district there is opening the year this
morning with the teachers on strike you
see the pictures there elise preston has
made her way to east high school that's
in columbus elise good morning why is
this happening there now
tony good morning to you the school
board and teachers union have been
negotiating for months without success
this ongoing strike means no one will be
in class here today students will begin
the school year online with many top by
substitutes
[Music]
teachers in columbus have been on strike
since monday
after the vast majority of the union's
roughly 4 500 members voted to reject
the latest contract offer from the
city's board of education
[Applause]
it marked yet another failed negotiation
after 22 meetings since march the union
claims columbus schools are in a state
of disrepair for missing ceiling tiles
to lead paint to water leaks
we will continue fighting until we have
safe
properly maintained and fully resourced
schools in every neighborhood the school
board says it's committed to addressing
those issues but insists they can only
be solved with more taxpayer dollars not
a contract with teachers what goes in
the contract doesn't actually solve that
problem as the unresolved negotiations
force a virtual start to the school year
the teachers union is calling on
families to honor the picket line by
boycotting remote class we're starting
off how we deal with covet the conflict
has put students like 16 year old inaiya
broome a senior at eastmore academy high
school in a tough position she told us
she'd rather be in person but supports
the strike we started off school with no
air no heat it's embarrassing compared
to these other school districts our
school has been the same for like 50
years
you're laughing
because my grandma went to the school
and she said the same thing like why
does it look exactly the same her mother
agrees but worries about how the
disruption and more remote class could
take a toll on some students i stand by
the teachers
but
this being the beginning of the school
year i think which is terrible for the
kids
and you can hear a lot of supporters
honking for this ongoing strike as it
continues the district has set up 25
running sites for students to pick up
free meals meanwhile the teachers union
and school board head back to the
bargaining table this afternoon